honestly my only question is I'm going
to get any press out of this you know
what I mean supposed to be quite a
you'll probably get some attention from
high-profile drama so the immigration
attorney who we we spoke to on the phone
the other
day needs a little more information but
she looked up your criminal charges yeah
and there's a few which are the
possession of a penis the possession of
a glass penis and then the possession of
a
penis um
so ice which is Immigration and Customs
Enforcement yeah I know what ice is you
know what ice is I'm just saying people
that may not
know you know they they don't really you
you don't get placed in a mental
health facility you just get put away in
a Cell so being trans being gay being
mental health issues or or your drug
issues you don't get any kind of
compensation for that you just get stuck
in a room and that's it and some
sometimes it takes months on end you
know that oh months months that's all it
would
take before they deport you before they
allegedly Deport me but if they deport
you if they deport me right so the first
the first charge you have to
clear you have to deal with is an um a
non-appearance for exposing yourself
exposing private parts and public
property that was that was West
Hollywood or Beverly
Hills
I played the fifth okay uh she said this
needs to and then there's also a battery
on a police a peace
officer not one I ple the on that one I
keep going and she said that needs to be
resolved uhuh but that might be resolved
if you address the mental health referr
if I address it from the mental health
standpoint which is I was suicidal we
all know this
so I'm
insane which would help clear a lot of
the charges I'm going try to seem like a
ma Val or anything just I'm really
terrified you know and then Beverly
Hills you had a possession of drug
paraphernalia and public
intoxication and she said and she said
if that drug paraphernalia has anything
to do with crack meth or fentanyl full
stop she says it's like you're screwed
I'm screwed it's not just like marijuana
it's it's it's a harder drug but there's
no possession charge uh it doesn't say
possession mhm possession of drug
paraphernalia so so we'll see what
happens
there but she she said again if you if
you comply with the mental health order
then that might might help
you and there and there's a third case a
third charge in West
Hollywood and and that hasn't been filed
by the court yet
and that wasn't filed in court yet no
that wasn't filed with the court yet so
it's a it's a tossup isn't it oh it's a
booking there'll be there will there
will be a charge but she doesn't know
what the details are yet and am I
allowed to in any way claim
innocence I mean I'm not I'm not a
lawyer I'm not a
judge I'm just I'm just telling you what
what what the attorney said he doesn't
want me anymore he wants you who's he
who is he who are you talking about
nothing I'm just I'm insane what how
about the charges won't
it and there was also a fake ID
charge that was dismissed mhm that was
dismissed
yeah and that one also has a mental
health
referral have you have you had a lawyer
in the
past yes or no public defender yeah have
you had a public defender so can I just
PSA real quick if anyone's watching this
just in case they come and snatch me
away hi my name is Rebecca Olson Mark
you a minute here and I a transgender
woman
pre- op or not I identify as a
woman if they come and snatch me if
anyone wants to start a Gund me and just
let it be known that I was taken right
and if anyone out there as a true
lawyer or anyone at all has anything to
do with the legal field and you that
they can help in my
case figure out where I am and give me a
call well I mean that's that's what
we're that's what who you that's who you
spoke to the other day was an attorney
yeah I spoke to her on the phone she
special is an
immigration an immigration but not
necessarily in a yeah so that you might
need that's true you might need another
attorney for this
stuff a slum but you might need to
curtail your drug use a little I'm doing
drugs and [__] ice Mark what's that
I'm not be doing drugs if I'm an Isa
you're going to be doing drugs I I said
I won't be you won't be right that's
what I'm saying you won't
be thank you Mar don't be smart with me
I'm trying to help you the humor I
appreciate I need all the ls I can get
right now s be my last night in America
my last night of
Freedom well you you know you brought
this on yourself that I will accept
yeah I'm not saying I didn't do anything
wrong all I am saying is under the
Geneva Convention human rights LGBT
rights I am allowed a fair trial here
and also they will kill me if I go back
to where I'm from I Won't Say I'm
terrified but I'm shaking in my boots
Mark please I need people to hear this
where I'm from they take a gay man or a
woman like me
seeing as you don't think I'm real
woman and they hang them from trees and
or throw them
into so this is an appeasement and or a
calling out to anyone and everyone out
there on the internet who says they may
or may not love me claim to know me
help this is an emergency Rea needs help
now you need an attorney I need more
than an attorney I need help yeah you
need you need mental health you need
drug help you need uh an attorney as
well we need a whole
team I can I can I do need a team that I
can agree with I can help you with all
of these for probably most of them then
why haven't you in the past because
you're you just always go off and get
high every time I get you even a hotel
room you you disappear and go get high
yes Mark I get high now it's time to get
low keep it professional here no I'm
just saying you you you're you you just
I've given you a room key and you just
you just walk away oh the room key to
what a hotel
room what hotel the one across the
street can you name it
Continental the
Continental Can you say the Continental
Hotel the Continental Hotel thank
you cuz I I tried to take you to the
InterContinental where Obama stayed and
they they wouldn't even let you walk up
the
stairs to the to the ironically because
of the black bouncer ironically no do
you think that was a racial thing it's
not a racial thing at all I just
consider it ironic
no African-American I don't think he
could have been white purple doesn't
matter he would no he definitely though
was black I'm just saying this being
from Africa being sent back to Africa
Mark please it's ironic
no on the there's a little irony there
but that had nothing to do with race it
has everything to do with race I think
it might had something to do with the
lipstick smeared all over your
face your your black feet your attitude
what you were wearing just your whole at
your r at palaski I mean I took you to
how many hotels that day three of them
none of them two of them even the
Continental wouldn't let you in that day
remember and then they let me in the
next day so either
way but they got they gave me I have
embarrassed myself they gave me a room
and I got you the key outside and then
you snuck up I understand that this is a
bit of a war here you really want to
fight I'm just trying to help you and
you're making it
this is doing nothing to quench my
nerves could you imagine more I ever
having a drink of water
again I'm not trying to quench your
nerves I'm trying to maybe make you
aware of this the seriousness of this
situation thank
you I know you you stubbornly want to
you don't want to give up drugs but I
think that's going to help you
here I'll be sober for my trial that's
for
sure and then if I succeed I'll
celebrate if not then at least I got to
for one
day but thank you America for everything
thank you for the
Liberty thank you for letting me do and
be whatever I wanted to do make me feel
like the woman that
I while not necessarily deserve to be in
all
humility but would rather
be no I mean I want the best for you
just like a lot of my viewers
do but we need your cooperation here I
need my cooperation sounds about right
yeah you need your cooperation you're
right wow is it something you just can't
control or is it something you can
control what drugs the drug use the I
can definitely control can you
control eat me drink me eat me drink
me eat me drink
me
you're
fascinating I want I want good things to
happen to you Rebecca but so do I do I
have that do I have
that on file on video Mark wants good
things for Rebecca can you say that
please did can you say Mark wants good
things forca I would love to see good
things happen say
Mark don't be a don't be a d please
please just say it it's my last request
my last wish we you say Mark has good
wish you're going to have about 20 more
requests huh you're going to have 20
more requests tonight you're going to
ask me for a room you're going to ask me
for a wig you're going to ask me for
money for drugs you're going ask me for
all this
stuff sounds about right I say it's your
last request I never asked for a room
you don't want a room it's going to rain
for 4 days huh it's going to rain for
the next four days lat later this week
oh it's been arranged suppos it's going
to rain oh it's going to rain you want
to walk around almost naked in the in
the cold rain won't be the first time I
know I'm just trying to help I'm I'm
trying to help you I'm not the enemy
then help me Mark maybe they'll be so
combative no but I think getting a hotel
room will help you from all right having
a cell will help me transition to
another
cell kind what I'm trying to do isn't it
well at least being CP up will help me
be able to get the resources I
need to at least start my
transition which I failed to do this
entire time I don't think the transition
is first on your list right now
transition is the top of my list what
about what about the deportations threat
they kind of go Han and Han don't they
they
don't they are literally the same thing
I think first things
first I think deportation is is the
deportation and then the
transition doctor
doctor sorry just let me have fun here
if this is my last night on Earth let me
have fun I could go to hell after this
or Heaven even worse the desert thank
you for that of water where I'm from
they take you out to the
desert and you don't get shot you're
just left
there I love you
Marcy do you think I have an advantage
here or not Mark I do not think you have
the
advantage that's right I think you have
a very strong disadvantage right now
based on what I've seen I've known you
for three
years you you you run to go get high
every single
scenario every every time we I give you
20 bucks 40 bucks even 100 bucks you
spend it on
drugs I believe in the future that all
narcotics will be
decriminalized I it's a funny case to
fight in California know considering the
Cannabis thing don't even smoke SED
anymore either way h e
LP
all right
well I'll get you a room do you want do
you want to go to rehab CU I think that
that would probably there's a 30-day
rehab I can set you up with what I need
to do is talk to this lawyer can we call
her now or tomorrow we try to call her
right now do we have to do this on
camera your decision or mine if you
would rather not it I I
will you you would you rather do this
not on camera I believe confidentiality
should be a clause here seeing us okay
I'll turn it off the camera let me just
get her numbered
down sounds about
right thank you goodbye for now thank
you car thank you love you I think Mark
wanted to speak to you anyway
hey
Carl
so did he have a chance a snowballs
chance in help well yeah he just gave
some really important information which
is he has a CLA filed somewhere
already so now we got to just keep
digging to find that okay so uh not
impossible very difficult very conf uh
long wait times for anything to deal
with the government do you need his
father's and mother's names I need his
father's name and his mother's name put
your bag down Mark if you can have me if
you can have me a phone so I can text
her personally because I want my
communication with her to be
confidential no okay all right all right
so he he wants it to be confidential
I'll have to get him a phone she he
sorry you're right
again this is all about gender at this
point she okay
um your phone tomorrow if not Monday
Mark the whole reason I want to stay in
the United States because I identify as
female I know you think that's funny to
you no it's all good I just I need to
get you a phone I don't have a you you
keep losing all the phones I have I had
a stash of phones you've lost every one
of them every one of
them sarcastic I'm trying to get I'm
trying to help you I'm sorry Jesus
you're so mean to me now what's going
on um all right so let me work on
getting him a phone so you guys can
speak
confidentially I'll keep you I'll keep
you updated thank you thank you Carla
yeah okay you're welcome you're welcome
thanks all by
bye all right I'll get you a phone so
you guys can speak
confidentially work I definitely hold
this time did she give you hope I hope
so I do too I have no optimism in life
I'm always prepared for the absolute
worst which in my case is quite a bit
but we don't need to talk about that do
I have your support Mark you have my
support I mean I got you an immigration
attorney I'm getting you a room I'm
getting you your rehab if you want it I
mental health all that stuff therapist
all of this but you have to cooperate I
can only do so much I can get these
things lined up for you but if you don't
show then I'm ready to cooperate with
the state on a solution here that is
mutually
beneficial and I fully appreciate every
Advantage I've been given so far the
United States government thank you very
much for even the
opportunity to be an
American and if I don't have your
support at the very least
I would like to
have
your
understanding I'm on your side are you
the government I'm
not then we
are not you but
us anyway Mark I haven't changed clothes
in like a week what's that I end up with
a purple heart oh yeah so they the
government with my purple
heart you keep the freedom no where
skirt in America you keep coordinating
with my
backdrops thank you and all I want to
say is
yes in the name of civil
liberty it is an inable right in the
United States of America to identify as
a woman not just freedom but to be a
woman and I would love you America to
know that that is the crime on trial
starting
today it's not about the right to be a
woman but being a woman in
itself I admit I currently am a man with
the appendage of a man but I am a woman
if you can hear me and that means
anything you in
anyway thank
you all right to be so it goes to women
either way to be
continued let's do our best he we're
going to do our best but you're going to
have to do part of the work probably
most of the work getting getting
yourself clean and straight it's going
to be some
work Fair
consideration you're a stone
fox
okay I got it thank
you